[Musique]
sont assez contents alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu on a décrypter pour vous
les missions d'hier et comme chaque
année le premier épisode sert à nous
présenter les candidats de la saison et
celle qui a fait le boss toute la soirée
sur les réseaux c'est quelqu'un que
j'adore moi c'est mon coup de coeur
c'est Elena voilà j'adore parce que
j'adore c'est un petit peu la Matthieu
de leur mot de Koh-Lanta
et dans un instant on aura notre Pascal
que j'adore parce Pascal candidat
emblématique qui sera avec nous pour
débriefer de ce lancement c'est parti
regardez Elena regardez c'est mon coup
de cœur je fais du sport depuis mon plus
jeune âge donc j'ai été gymnase de haut
niveau Belgique après j'ai fait du
triathlon j'ai fait de l'équitation j'ai
fait de la boxe thaï donc je suis assez
éclectique j'ai un style de vie vraiment
parfait comme on veut dire je sais que
je suis une source d'inspiration aussi
pour beaucoup de personnes depuis que je
suis toute petite je me bats au sport au
sport au sport souvent on me demande
pourquoi je pense qu'à ça pourquoi je
fais que ça ben maintenant ils ont vu
là vraiment on est quatre sur une coco
donc ça fait une demi ici vous avez vu
comment j'étais compter par contre les
gars pourquoi il y en a que quatre il y
en a pas d'autres franchement il va
falloir instaurer quelques petites
règles ceux qui veulent parler peut-être
aller un peu plus loin une belle odeur
de melon qui se dégage de ces étals
j'adore il est là
et en effet que j'adore c'est Pascal
notre Pascal candidat emblématique de
Koh-Lanta merci Pascal d'être là bonsoir
mon chéri tu es bien je reviens de
vacances
alors on va revenir sur Elena et puis on
va faire le débrief avec Pascal qui
connaît mieux que lui Koh-Lanta ici
personne en tout cas Elena qui était
chargé de créer l'équipe rouge l'équipe
des tinago on peut dire qu'elle a eu le
néfin et le nez creux même parce qu'elle
a choisi que des candidats qu'il
adoraient
ou pas regardez ces débat regarde Elena
c'est à vous maintenant on va choisir
Elodie Elodie
je la trouve beaucoup trop arrogante je
suis d'accord qu'on est là pour gagner
mais sans écraser les autres et ça j'ai
un peu de mal Alexandre je vais vous
demander de rejoindre l'équipe des
rouges j'ai pas envie de vivre une
aventure avec quelqu'un comme ça et je
préfère vivre une aventure avec des gens
qui se jugent pas meilleur
pouvez choisir Christine Christine je
préfère être avec Nicolas Anne-Sophie
Anne-Sophie
c'est pas une tuile c'est juste pas ma
préférence et
c'est pas ma préférence je suis vraiment
très satisfaite de mon choix d'équipe
c'est le début d'aventure ça se passe
vraiment comme je le fais
Pascal qu'est-ce que tu as pensé du
Koh-Lanta je vais vous faire tout le
débrief dans un instant qu'est-ce que tu
as pensé honnêtement moi j'étais limite
pas trop envie de le regarder j'ai été
agréablement surpris très très
agréablement je suis un peu d'accord
avec toi je trouve que c'est très très
mal
au départ ils ont mis ils ont ils ont
ils ont été pas mal ça me rappelle un
peu mon casting de l'époque là et de
2015 ils ont fait un beau casting un peu
plus mixé
puis il y a des gros tempérament c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal après on a aussi
découvert Célia Célia ça fait 14 ans
qu'elle attendait de faire Koh-Lanta
mais elle a bien fait d'attendre si
longtemps
les 14 ans je m'inscris chaque année et
14 ans je me prépare alors je peux vous
assurer que je suis prête une petite
très près jusqu'au 40e jour 40ème jour
ah ouais c'est vraiment la nana à voir
dans son équipe elle hein Célia pas
choisi non plus vous allez rejoindre
l'équipe des jaunes je le comprends
totalement et je leur pardonne ouais ça
va c'est le premier jour Célia la NR
solide de toute façon c'est moi qui suis
en danger Célia et pétri d'angoisse elle
est donc partie illico à la recherche
d'une arme stratégique ah ouais quand
même du coup va falloir y aller au bluff
là j'espère que les bétons l'avantage
stratégique a été trouvé ah mais non
c'est pas ça mais c'est moi qui l'ai
trouvé ah non je l'ai vu déjà mais
un vieux bout de bois
[Musique]
tout à fait
la première émission mais il te reste
plein jusqu'à la finale Célia les
aventuriers de la tribu jaune ont décidé
de vous éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable
parti direct elle est partie comme ça
partie trop vite
Pascal parce que ça sera rare
je trouve que trop faible
et à force de vouloir faire des gens un
peu comme nous des monsieur et madame
tout le monde il y a plus rien ils ont
voulu tout le monde
toi tu es monsieur madame tout le monde
parle comme ça ils ont voulu privilégier
la stratégie c'est ce qui va se passer
durant la saison et je trouve que ça
manque de tempérament on s'est ennuyé un
peu moi j'ai pas du tout été passionné
et l'histoire du feu sacré on y comprend
rien une sorte d'avantage donné à
quelqu'un franchement
je te le dis alors on a découvert aussi
Élodie Elodie c'est un peu l'ovni de
cette saison surtout que c'est un peu
enflammé hier elle a cru que Koh-Lanta
c'était l'émission de sa mère regardez
je m'appelle Elodie j'ai 35 ans et je
suis responsable marketing et
communication dans le jeu de société
jeux de société coup de pied en l'air
bosse une zinzin mon crépu Cachon de
celle-ci
[Musique]
le chant représente pour moi thérapie au
quotidien et je suis la plus heureuse du
monde je suis pétillante déterminée
haute perché maladroite aussi
on s'amuse en tout cas j'espère que sur
le corps va être moins excité
[Musique]
mais du coup elle va bien dormir et les
autres aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va falloir qu'elle trouve une
solution pour dormir la guerrière là je
peux faire un truc de nœud c'est bon je
ne veux pas que mon corps touche le sol
donc ni dans la cabane ni sur le sable
et ben du coup je suis en hauteur et
j'ai un voilà je suis bien là une
guerrière qui est bien c'est une
guerrière qui dort bien cette nuit a été
la nuit la plus longue de ma vie j'ai
perdu 15 ans
allez mon perso
il y a des bons personnages il y en a
beaucoup aimé il y en a beaucoup j'ai du
mal à trouver un préféré non mais c'est
parce que obligatoirement de suite on va
sentais pas que moi j'étais un peu comme
toi cette saison je te dis la vérité je
sais pas comme un fou ouais moi aussi et
là mais bon c'est le mardi soir c'est
insupportable donc ça arrive et vendredi
soir TF1 4002 ils font quoi s'il y a pas
Koh-Lanta le mardi
soir c'est vendredi soir Koh-Lanta c'est
la règle non et puis il mange toujours
que même que l'or divertissement du
vendredi soir marcherait peut-être mieux
même le mardi enfin
parce que là c'est le vendredi soir la
concurrence est dur aussi mais Koh-Lanta
c'est le vendredi soir problème c'est
que tu as les enfants les enfants le
problème c'est que les enfants regardent
beaucoup Koh-Lanta la c'est les vacances
mais dans deux semaines tu vas voir que
le mardi soir ça va s'effondrer mais ça
va faire quoi que TF1 n'est pas assez
intelligent pour comprendre qu'il faut
le mettre le vendredi
moi aussi j'ai voulu créer des cases ici
j'ai tout de suite vu que voilà un
moment quand je sais que ça marche pas
ça marche pas
intelligente sur un truc c'est que on
peut dire ce qu'on veut mais ils sont
pas débile TF1 ils se rendent bien
compte des chiffres et tout ça il y a
quelqu'un il y a un truc qui vise ils
insistent pas dans le vide non parce
qu'ils veulent pas se déguster tu crois
parce que il va pas revenir le vendredi
mais il faut venir le vendredi c'est
clair Koh-Lanta même Koh-Lanta c'est le
plus faible lancement de Koh-Lanta de
l'histoire oui mais est-ce que c'est le
mardi parce que c'est pas grave je te
dis vendredi il faut un million de plus
ils l'ont lancé je pense vendredi là je
te jure qu'il faisait exceptionnellement
comme celui-ci c'est le plus bas c'est
pas dû à autre chose que
alors il y a des scandales
ça aussi
ça c'est compliqué hein tu penses quoi
tu penses que ça joue euh ça jouait
beaucoup parce que en fait beaucoup de
scandales se sont mis il y a la légende
de la triche qui a été énorme ça et
c'est ce qui a fait le plus mal dans
l'histoire de ça ça les amis par terre
ça c'est clair et net derrière l'alterne
l'avant-dernière saison bon c'était
moyen mais il y avait encore un petit
peu des scandales avec ce port François
le pompier bon peu importe et là la
première s'habille tout le monde par
terre c'est c'est je pense que là lui il
les a c'est le scandale qui a fait du
mal donnez-moi l'heure tu penses que les
gens il y a une solidarité avec les
femmes il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
doivent dire lui il est pas question que
je revois sa tête je le vois les réseaux
et ça marque sa voix je la supporte plus
son comportement je supporte plus on y
est on n'a pas fait un énorme buzz mine
de rien je trouve ça a été drôlement
étouffé quand même parce que moi je
trouve c'est un gros scandale il y a des
gilets des dommages collatéraux hein
allez pas demander à Charlotte et à
Jean-Luc son mari dans quel état ils
sont Jean-Luc sa femme se fait insulter
alors tu es incroyable et Jean-Luc sa
femme se fait insulter dans la vie
normale
allez demander à la jeune fille qui est
toujours en psychiatrie là depuis je
suis
c'est compliqué elles peuvent même pas
l'interviewer ils peuvent même pas
parler en tout cas toi Pascal dit la
vérité
moi je regarderai pas cause de ça il est
alors depuis quelques temps il s'avère
que moi j'ai fait 2016 à la télé j'avais
un mec en face de moi super humain très
discret pas de réseau sociaux il était
il était il était calme et on le
respectait aussi parce que il
intervenait pas on le voyait pas c'était
sur le jeu et sinon on le voyait pas et
en 2017 qu'en 2018 quand j'ai refait
qu'on le deuxième Koh-Lanta c'était plus
du tout le même personnage il avait pris
il s'était étouffé il a évolué on a vu
son évolution en tant qu'animateur il
prend beaucoup de place et là ça reste
que mon mon que ma vision il a pété les
boulons en 2018 il avait déjà pété les
boulons la tête elle est devenue comme
ça et ses comportements il les a déjà eu
quand même avec des joueurs avec
d'autres personnes donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'il arrive je vous dis la vérité quand
c'est arrivé il y a quelques semaines je
me suis dit [__] enfin ça y est ça y
est ça sort comment il est mais soyons
honnêtes maintenant au tour de la table
n'est pas au courant de son copain alors
je vais dire
Pascal moi ça fait très longtemps que je
l'ai pas vu Denis et je vais dire et
Denis il a été en amour avec moi parce
que c'est lui qui a fait la première
émission de l'amour en 2012 c'est lui
qui avait été accepté de faire la
première émission de TPMP donc
franchement j'étais comme un fou il
avait dit oui alors que personne n'avait
déjà vu l'émission sur France 4 donc je
me suis dit ce mec là est un amour et
c'est vrai que je l'ai recroisé deux
trois fois on s'est joué en tournoi de
tennis malheureusement il a perdu et
c'est vrai qu'il était énervé mais bon
ça je peux je peux comprendre ça je peux
comprendre
mais sinon sinon
et voilà à chaque fois que j'ai vu l'été
il perd sympathique j'ai pas vu depuis
10 ans depuis on est quoi en 2022 je
l'ai pas eu depuis 8 ans voilà depuis 6
7 8 ans voilà j'ai pas vu depuis non
mais là où tu dis pardon c'est pas pour
mentir j'ai jamais rencontré de ma vie
donc quand tu dis tout le monde savait
euh je l'ai vécu sur le jeu en fait
c'est que c'est toujours je reste dans
mon analyse et ce que j'ai vu et ce que
qui est vraiment vu c'est que où vous
êtes un physique un peu un peu qui prend
de la place et là il va pas s'affronter
j'ai eu le cas sur le l'orientation et
la reculé et mais après derrière il vous
punir à préparer par contre on va pas
rentrer dans les détails ce qu'il a fait
avec moi on s'en fout je suis pas là
pour pour régler ça mais et avec les
femmes avec la femme entre guillemets là
il a un pouvoir par dessus et là il se
laisse aller quoi c'est la salut
tu as fait des coups
j'ai pas envie on dirait que je reviens
ici
c'est fait
des lives il veut pas je m'en fous c'est
pas grave c'est fini moi c'est loin tout
ça maintenant c'est derrière Pascal
j'adore mais j'ai pas envie d'en parler
il m'a piqué ma femme je m'en fous j'en
ai rien à [__]
oui j'étais tranquille parce que je m'en
fous
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai quoi c'est vrai on
passe Pascal non mais moi je me rappelle
du du de la fois que j'étais chroniqueur
juste avant de rentrer ici il y avait
des personnes avec moi des chroniqueurs
et tout et tout le monde certains en ont
parlé et on avait ras-le-bol et ils sont
là ils sont là encore ce soir
on a eu beaucoup de décès
qui sont certains sont là certains sont
plus là mais j'ai chopé la conversation
j'ai dit mais tu veux que Gilles Verdez
non j'étais pas là oh non tu n'étais pas
là
[Rires]
Pascal tu es Fatou la première fois
c'était lors de la viande du
documentaire de Marie bartolano c'est la
première fois qu'on a un peu évoqué ça
mais de très très loin sans citer sans
citer Charlotte
de passer ton temps
si vous vous le dites ou pas comment
entre anciens candidats de Koh-Lanta
donc c'est compliqué ouais il y a une
nuance quand même est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un de colérique avec un gros
caractère comme c'est que souvent le cas
dans le milieu et ça la rigueur ça va
être normal est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui harcèle vraiment c'est ça la
question qu'on se pose mais on peut pas
appeler du harcèlement c'est-à-dire que
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui
c'est où la punition ou alors il se
passe ce qui s'est passé avec Charlotte
et les autres personnes
regardez joueur qui n'a à ma saison
on peut pas être sérieux
je suis pas allé à la finale et d'autres
personnes ont on la finale devait être à
Paris et elle a été mis au cinéma Le
Grand Rex il y a Jérémy Javier plusieurs
joueurs quand il a su ça il s'en est
pris entre guillemets arabière il y a
mis plus bas que terre raviron a pleuré
ravir m'appelle me dit moi-même on le
met de Twitter il punit avec ses outils
c'est pas grave mais pour certains c'est
très lourd pour les joueurs de Koh-Lanta
c'est c'est ça frôle un peu une sexe on
est puni on a plus d'Oni Brogniart qui
vous suit on a plus Denis Brogniart qui
vous parle c'est c'est très lourd voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut mettre dans le
contexte Koh-Lanta c'est c'est vraiment
un monde à part on n'est pas comme
toutes les autres émissions je ne sais à
part
tu as raison parce que en tout cas
Pascal j'aime bien
sûr
je peux m'énerver des fois
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui après je voudrais une donner une
info mais il y a un risque que vous
m'apportiez un démenti formel est-ce que
je peux essayer quand même alors pour
l'instant tu vas fermer ta gueule
j'en avais parlé un peu de son
comportement il y a quelques temps mais
tu voulais pas en parler tu es vexé bien
sûr une fois de plus tu as dit Pascal
bon hein ok tu dis n'importe quoi
et tu dis non là c'est Pascal exagéré et
là il se passe ça alors toi
qui dit nouvelle saison des nouvelles
règles de Koh-Lanta et cette année on a
découvert la règle du feu sacré
on va pas se raconter l'histoire je suis
toujours en train d'essayer de la
comprendre
dépositaire du talisman du feu sacré et
ce talisman vous donne la possibilité de
choisir entre deux alternatives soit
vous utilisez le pouvoir de ce talisman
à titre personnel soit vous avez envie
d'en faire profiter quelqu'un sachez en
tout cas Nicolas que si vous décidez
d'utiliser le pouvoir de votre talisman
pour un autre aventurier
tout le Conseil terminé si vous n'êtes
pas abonné le talisman vous revient et
vous le conservez claire j'ai rien
compris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous aviez une info à donner oui alors
là où je rejoins Pascal c'est
qu'effectivement il y a un vrai problème
Denis brogniat il y a un tel problème de
libre Brogniart que si le programme est
un peu usé du côté de la production
selon mes infos on considère que c'est
quand même beaucoup de sa faute de sa
responsabilité et alors qu'il
l'incarnait totalement le programme
depuis des années qu'il semblait de voir
y rester encore très longtemps pour la
première fois on évoque peut-être un
changement de présentateur de Koh-Lanta
et il y a un nom qui a circulé bouder
qui est qui a d'ailleurs un peu le même
profil que Denis Brogniart parce que
c'est un journaliste qui
présente qui était à Canal+ qui est
passé Grégoire Margoton voilà selon mes
infos Grégoire Margotton pour être le
successeur de l'année Brogniart si
j'avais à choisir un successeur de Denis
Brogniart ce serait Grégoire Margotton
donc ce sera lui non pas du tout
là-dedans
je vous jure que c'est vrai mais moi
j'ai pensé la dernière je vous jure que
c'est vrai et je me dis si un jour Denis
Brogniart il dit qu'il arrête Koh-Lanta
pour quelques raisons que ce soit je
trouve que celui qui pourrait le
remplacer qu'il a une voix très légitime
très reconnaissable et dans ma tête je
me suis dit pourquoi pas Grégoire
Margottin mais moi j'ai un avoir
là-dedans
il va faire 6 millions du jour au
lendemain
tu sais quoi c'est parfois tu sais des
petits changements regarde c'est comme
quand j'ai
dit
quand
parfois je comprends pas mais
Jean-Michel au repos
ben quand il revient tu vois ça ça
toujours il va avoir un effet curiosité
quand même attention il y a toujours un
petit effet de curiosité Grégoire
ça fait 23 millions de téléspectateurs
après après je crois pas que ce soit
l'ordre du jour et je vais venir comme
vous l'avez dit c'est sûr et certain
maintenant que Denis Brognard va rester
euh c'est sûr
des formats comme ça pardon je suis ravi
pour Browner qui vient de l'argent mais
pardon tu changes d'ADN maintenant
je crois que tu l'aimes pas trop toi
c'est pas pareil c'est pour ça que
j'adore les taux que moi parce que
vraiment le taux que ça les fogiels toi
tout ça les Ruquier ça repose vraiment
sur quelqu'un tu perds la personne tu
perds l'essence et tu regardes Koh-Lanta
il y a tu regardes un format ou tu
regardes exactement
vous allez me sucer jusqu'à quelle heure
[Applaudissements]
21h14 c'est bon
c'est dans la boîte est-ce qu'il y a une
question sur Koh-Lanta est-ce que vous
avez demandé si on les était content ou
pas si les gens étaient contents ou pas
ah bah tiens on voulait qu'on a fait
magnéto sur Denis c'est devenu aussi un
même regardez oui oui sur Twitter en moi
2 secondes
j'ai gagné pour ah c'est pas gagnant
encore
j'ai gagné pour ah c'est pas gagné
et cette épreuve cette épreuve il
fallait mettre une boule dans un trou je
la ferai le 8 mars
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ça de ma mère
Pascal tu sais que c'est un bonheur de
devoir à chaque fois
n'ont pas à 4 à 50 et quelques pourcents
c'est non 57 % ils n'ont pas aimé le
retour de Koh-Lanta c'est dommage il
faut je pense qu'il faut qu'ils accroche
parce que honnêtement hier je me suis
régalé en plus de faire l'équipe le
lendemain ça laisse un peu de créer une
relation entre tous et top puis il y a
beaucoup de personnages avec Nicolas bon
c'est encore ça donc lui il est
obligatoirement
non mais il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes
[Rires]
après revue il est revenu une fois non
il me semble il est revenu dans un bois
longtemps exactement
[Rires]